samedi il faut savoir que c'est là la
journée de la snsm des sauveteurs en mer
c'est la journée de la collecte des dons
et j'ai trouvé que c'était un moment
fort pour signer ce partenariat dans
lequel odyssea nous demande d'être le
partenaire sécurité des routes bleues
quoi ça consiste alors ça consiste pour
odyssea dupliquer le format des stations
de ski sur les routes bleues et donc
les quatre stations de la martinique qui
sont celles de fort-de-france de
case-pilote de france du françois et du
marin seront amenés à suivre les
diverses événements que nous allons
que nous allons sur lesquels nous allons
nous positionner et pour lesquels
odyssea nous demandera de venir pour une
veille de la prévention ou de la
sécurité
alors quels sont les avantages pour de
tels partenariats mais c'est important
pour nous parce que vous savez que au
niveau de la snsm 80% de nos de notre de
nos moyens financiers viennent de dons
des legs de mécénat ce partenariat nous
permet avec odyssea de pouvoir oeuvrer
sur toute la communication tant en
matériel de communication quand
diffusion est en préparation de
films et de spots qui permettra à la
snsm de martinique d'être visible sur
l'europe sur l'international sur la
nationale et sur la martinique